[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ceux ravi de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de mode
d'emploi votre magazine consacré à
l'actualité de l'emploi et de la
formation professionnelle tout de suite
le sommaire de cette édition
saint quentin en yvelines poursuit le
développement du campus numérique avec
l'installation d'une nouvelle école
elancourt la structure simplon elle
propose de formation pour devenir
développeur web et développeurs data
focus sur une entreprise de coignières
rcb informatique installé depuis 1986
spécialiste dans l'installation et la
maintenance de systèmes informatiques
nous nous sommes rendus sur place
enfin nous recevons ivement geely
président directeur général de
l'entreprise 4dconcept spécialisée dans
le numérique est installé à montigny le
bretonneux
pour commencer direction coignières dans
une pme familiale
elle est spécialisée dans les services
informatiques et propose des solutions
cloud ou la maintenance du matériel
informatique pour les particuliers ou
les entreprises est actuellement et
recherche plusieurs employés regarder
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude
nous sommes ici dans le magasin de rcb
informatique une pme installée depuis
1986 à coignières elle réalise près de 3
millions de chiffre d'affaires et
emploie 20 salariés
nous allons rencontrer son dirigeant
yann rolland
[Musique]
en compagnie de yann rolland président
de rcv informatique bonjour bonjour
alors en quoi consiste votre activité
ici à coignières alors rcb informatique
est une entreprise spécialisée dans la
maintenance et d'infogérance
informatique
nos clients sont des particuliers mais
également des entreprises et donc il
vous pourvoyez des postes actuellement
quels sont ils
oui alors toute l'année nous recrutons
des techniciens systèmes et réseaux
également des administrateurs pour
intervenir chez nos clients entreprises
et tpe des pme mais aussi des
techniciens passionnés de mac et de pc
pour dépanner nos clients dans nos
points de vente de coignières et
versailles et en quoi consistent ces
missions du coût de ces postes là alors
à la fois en magasin pour dépanner les
ordinateurs de clients des ordinateurs
qui sont en panne ou bien qui veulent
augmenter les capacités de leur
ordinateur et pour notre clientèle
entreprise c'est faire de la maintenance
informatique de la sécurité
s'assurer que leur infrastructure
informatique est toujours performante et
actuellement vous recherchez combien de
personnes et quel profil vous recherchez
pour charge différents profils ont
chargé un administrateur système et
réseau là c'est plutôt pour notre
activité entreprise donc ce sont des
techniciens d'un niveau bac + 2 à bac +
4 qui vont intervenir chez nos clients
pour s'assurer du bon fonctionnement de
leur système d'information est également
des techniciens informatiques pc et mac
pour faire du dépannage informatique et
justement nous allons rejoindre lucas
fontaine il est technicien systèmes et
réseaux depuis quatre mois ici dans
cette entreprise
[Musique]
et nous rejoignons luc africaine bonjour
bonjour alors en quoi consiste ce poste
de technicien systèmes et réseaux alors
en fait d'un poste de technicien
systèmes et réseaux
on a essentiellement deux axes de
travail le premier en fait ça va être de
résoudre les petits soucis que peuvent
rencontrer nos que nos clients tous les
jours donc ça peut aller en fait d'un
accès au serveur qui ne fonctionne plus
ça peut aussi être une imprimante tout
bêtement qui ne fonctionne plus on va
les aider en fait à pouvoir travailler
tous les jours sans avoir le en ayant le
moins d'interruptions possible et dans
un second temps fait sa lettre de
démission un petit peu plus ce qu'on
appelle administratif ou en fait on va
venir gérer le système du client par
exemple quelqu'un qui adore d'une
élévation dans ses droits
pour accéder à des ressources des choses
comme ça on est aussi capable de le
faire d accompagner pour pour que la
boîte soit vraiment optimisé comme comme
il le désire donc on est beaucoup avec
des pme donc des petites et moyennes
entreprises qui situe en allant de 5 6
postes à une trentaine ou une
quarantaine une cinquantaine de postes
donc voilà on ne sait vraiment très
varié il ya des cabinets d'avocats des
associations caritatives
on a vraiment un petit peu de tout et
c'est ça aussi qui fait du coup notre
notre bonne expérience
alors si des personnes qui nous
regardent souhaite faire ce métier quels
conseils vous pouvez leur donner et ce
qu' ils peuvent quitter leur emploi et
venir directement postuler ici où est ce
qu'ils doivent passer par une formation
numérique
alors je conseille quand même assez
personnes effectivement de suivre une
formation
sauf si jamais c'est des gens qui
touchent un petit peu à tout ça depuis
qu'ils sont petits qui sont qui sont
très très très à l'aise mais sinon je
conseille quand même de passer des
formations il y en a énormément dans le
monde de l'informatique
petites formations qui peuvent aller de
deux semaines à plusieurs mois donc
vraiment vous pouvez avoir une vraiment
choisir votre formation par rapport à un
besoin un besoin d'une entreprise que
vous aurez ciblées donc voila moi par
exemple je sais que j'en ai passé une
qui était sur le réseau ça a pris quand
même quatre ou cinq mois avant de la
passer
c'était assez compliqué mais voilà c'est
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui quand vous
le mettez sur glace et les employeurs
justement sont friandes c'est de cette
certification etc
merci beaucoup varié si vous souhaitez
rejoindre comme lucas fontaine cette
entreprise rendez vous sur le site
www.rcfh.ru informatiques point fr nous
accueillons maintenant ivement gili
président directeur général de la
société cnim antenne 4dconcept bonsoir
bonsoir
alors avant de parler de votre activité
de vos besoins en main d'oeuvre je vous
propose de découvrir la formation aux
métiers du numérique une priorité de
saint quentin en yvelines avec son
campus numérique composée de cinq
structures des formations allant du
community manager au data artisans ou
encore aux développeurs web nous sommes
rendus dans la nouvelle école simple ont
installé à elancourt est ouverte depuis
le 26 décembre 2018 regardez programmés
ou codées un jeu de dominos le projet
sur lequel travaillent les 23 prenante
de la promotion développeurs web de
l'école simplon avec un esprit
d'entraidé entre les personnes formées
des profils différents avec plus ou
moins d'expérience dans le numérique on
démarre à partir d'une page vide et ont
créé le code en entier ce qui nous donne
un rendu qu'on peut visualiser
directement on fait des tutoriaux pour
sa prendre les uns aux autres ce que
sont les notions
de javascript je voulais compléter mon
expérience de graphistes développeurs
web et dans le domaine de la
communication pour être une
professionnelle complète
je pense que les intervenants en selle
très bien les coups je comprends
parfaitement les apprenants viennent
d'horizons différents le plus jeune a 20
ans et le plus âgé 52 ans porté par
saint quentin en yvelines simple on
accueille aussi 20 apprenants dans une
promotion de développeurs date à une
table une base de données relationnelle
de clients de produits et de
transactions ce qui implique des
factures des transactions et ainsi de
suite
on s'est parlé en fait aux des
différentes bases de données
quand on reçoit des données par exemple
on commence dans une nouvelle boîte ils
ont plein de plein de donner du style
des clients des noms de clients des
adresses etc
il faut tout simplement les mettant un
tableur histoire que ce soit plus clair
trier faciles à retrouver
potentiellement rechargeable
35 heures de formation par semaine du
lundi au vendredi sur sept mois avec à
la clé un diplôme équivalent bac + 2 un
formateur pour chacune des promotions et
une pédagogie proactive pour les
apprenants
le but c'est pour chaque apprenant oda
prenantes
c'est de s'autoformer donc ils sont en
groupe il travaille trés principalement
toujours en mode projet ça veut dire que
de trouver la ressource par eux mêmes
dans un premier temps à la fin de la
formation prévue le 31 juillet ils
seront considérés comme des développeurs
juniors une deuxième promotion et déjà
prévu les dates ne sont pas encore
déterminées alors ils vont manger dit
juste avant de vous faire réagir par
rapport aux sujets qu'on vient de voir
un mot sur votre activité qu'est ce que
c'est 4dconcept société d'ingénierie
documentaire
donc en fait ingénierie documentaire
c'est plusieurs choses c'est d'abord
d'être capable de structurer une
information pour être capable de
l'exploiter de l'enrichir de la publier
et en fait pour ça il ya des systèmes
ses complexes pour par exemple produire
un magazine dont vous imaginez que pour
produire un magazine faut d'abord le
rédiger faut gérer tout un tas
d'informations dans des bases de données
puis ensuite faut publier font publier
pour vous puissiez l'acheter dans un
kiosque au format papier
il faut aussi de publier pour consulter
de plus en plus sur des sites internet
et puis aussi maintenant sur des plates
formes mobiles sur votre téléphone sur
les ipad et tout ça mais voilà ces
métiers deviennent des concepts et donc
on vient voir l'école simple ont
finalement être formés aux développeurs
web et date à céder métier qu'on
retrouve chez vous oui tout à fait on
retrouve ce type de métier on retrouve
beaucoup chez kate des concepts des gens
qui déjà des profils sur la tout ce
qu'ils aient connaissance de la
structuration de l'information donc les
langages html pour le web mais également
le xml pour pour la gestion de
l'information puis après il ya le java
pour tout ce qui est développement des
gros back office de traitement de
données et puis effectivement des
profils encore différent plus + web
javascript http et html pour pour les
parties feront office qu'on appelle nous
les ferons tous fils en fait la partie
web alors qu'historiquement vous est
basée dans les yvelines ça fait 25 ans
que vous existez 30 ans cette année dans
cette année intense et plus de 25 ans
donc et du coup comment se porte votre
activité
ça a évolué comment ça évolue plutôt
bien
parce qu'en fait 4dconcept a toujours
été beaucoup focalisé sur le numérique
est en fait la transformation numérique
et qui s'est accéléré ces dernières
années avec les toutes les plates formes
mobiles qui sont à disposition
maintenant on fait de tout le monde et
donc forcément en fait ça permet à 4 des
concepts de très bien se développer
vous avez un chiffre d'affaires
d'environ on a un chiffre d'affaires
d'environ 7 millions d'euros qui
seraient partis à 50% sur le
développement logiciel et 50% sur une
activité plus d'intégration et de
développement mais un taux de croissance
ont en moyenne en moyenne de 15 à 20%
par an alors qui dit une croissance de
15 à 20% par an 10 nouveaux employés
besoins de main d'oeuvre est
actuellement vous recherchez des
personnes tout à fait et si c'était
assez compliqué parce que le marché de
l'informatique est assez tendue c'est
toujours très compliqué former des
ressources dans nos métiers c'est aussi
quelque chose d'assez longs donc en fait
ils fectivement donc à la base on
cherche des gens qui ont un profil de
développeurs une formation développement
mais après on leur apporte aussi
beaucoup de complément pour être capable
d'intervenir sur nos systèmes et alors
justement actuellement vous recherchez
un ingénieur un développeur web
ingénieur développeur on va voir la
fiche de l'offre d'emploi que vous
proposez actuellement s'afficher à
l'écran est ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler justement les caractéristiques
qu'il faut avoir pour prétendre occuper
ce poste
les caractéristiques de base en fait
sont assez classiques donc en fait très
généralement c'est à peu près un bac + 2
c'est des connaissances en php
javascript les technologies du web est
encore une fois après c'est des gens
qu'on continuera de former et à qui on
apportera un certain nombre de
compléments d'informations notamment sur
tout ce qui est interface hui interface
eu x pour être capable de bien présenter
l'information sur les interfaces web et
si on peut faire le lien est ce que les
l'aller les étudiants les apprenants de
simplon peuvent postuler prétendre à ce
poste au bout d'eux vous êtes notre
formation bien sûr pourquoi pas je
connais pas exactement le cursus de
formation mais certainement et eux peu
pourquoi rejoindre votre entreprise si
vous deviez présenter les arguments
ah parceque 4dconcept une petite
entreprise nous avons des projets très
innovants
on a aussi un atmosphère de travail
auquel on fait très attention à
parce que je pense que c'est important
les gens doivent être bien dans leur
lieu de travail pour vraiment s'épanouir
alors si vous souhaitez postuler vous
pouvez envoyer votre cv et votre lettre
de motivation sur l'adresse mail qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran recrutement
@ 4dconcept point fr il mange il y merci
d'être venu sur notre plateau merci vous
êtes pdg de 4dconcept une entreprise
spécialisée dans le numérique à montigny
le bretonneux
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis vous pouvez revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
ou sur l'application mobile tv 78 on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
non